see in the Soviet Union with
Solzhenitsyn wrote about the Soviet
Union and it's pathologist it it's sort
of peaked in terms of its pathological
authoritarianism when it became illegal
to complain that your life wasn't going
well and you just think about how
horrible that is say because because you
know lots of times your life isn't going
well I mean and I don't mean this in
some casual way I mean maybe I don't
know maybe you have diabeetus in your
you know maybe you're gonna lose your
your feet or something like it's really
not it's nothing trivial that's going on
here something is not good
or maybe it's economic or maybe you're
unemployed or and but you see the idea
in the Soviet Union was well we already
have all the answers everything's
perfect already
that's what totalitarians think well if
everything is perfect and you're
suffering then well maybe there's
something wrong with you because
everything is perfect after all and if
you're suffering then what are you to
come out and say well I'm suffering it's
like well then your evidence that things
aren't perfect right you're like a widow
or an orphan in an Old Testament story
you know when the Kings got to high and
mighty then they wouldn't pay enough
attention to the widows and the orphans
and then the profit would come along and
say you know those widows and orphans a
lot more important than you think they
are and if you don't pay attention to
them properly then things are gonna fall
apart around you in a way that you just
can't even imagine and so well then
you're sort of like your own Widow and
your own orphan but you don't get to say
hey look you know things aren't perfect
yet because I'm actually having still
quite a rough time here you don't get to
admit to your own suffering if you can't
admit to your own suffering then you
certainly see the suffering especially
the additional suffering the excess
suffering should be treated as evidence
that you're not doing something quite
right yet it should be treated as
evidence that you're wrong there's
something important that you're doing
that's wrong
I understand how harsh that is and I'm
not saying that everyone who's suffering
is suffering because they're doing
something in some simple way that's
wrong I was in a elevator once in a
hospital
very terrifying thing and this person
got on who was just in an absolute state
of shock you know I mean it was really
not good and I don't remember how this
happened but I engaged the person in
conversation and they just said that
they had just had been diagnosed with
what looked to be terminal cancer and
what was horrifying about it was that
what they were doing was going over
their life in the elevator trying to
figure out what they had done in order
to deserve such a fate you know they've
immediately taken it on themselves as a
moral failing and that's not what I'm
saying you can't come up to someone who
has cancer and say well if you weren't
such a bloody idiot throughout your
whole life you wouldn't have cancer and
believe me that happens a lot more than
you think
and people who have diseases like that
get blamed for it that's not what I'm
saying it's not like that it's it's it's
it's a more generalized attitude that is
that if life isn't yet what it should be
then you have a response you have a
primary responsibility to do something
about it and the place to start looking
is to your own errors and to fix them
and that's and that's that's that's a
safe bet man because you're probably
doing some things that you would
wouldn't have to be doing that if you
fixed would make things better so it's
time to let go and to sacrifice who you
are for who you could become